the emperor is Mac in his kingdom  growing up is never easy  but in nature schoolyard and article  offers a particularly tough education  yet for the emperor penguin the most  uninhabitable place on earth is called  marching bar and away into the  mysterious unknown discovering love  embracing fatherhood fighting for  survival  [Music]  searching for home  [Music]  forced through unforgiving yet  mesmerizing landscapes propelled by an  ancient call to the scene  [Music]  this is the story of two destinies one  with a lifetime of experience and the  other just beginning the old Emperor  gives way and the story of a new emperor  begins  march of the Penguins to the next step  [Music]